dominic waghorn now reports from the
capital colombo and his report contains
flashing images from the start
sri lankans may have risen up and
demanded change but this is their new
president i would like to bring everyone
together a close ally of the one they've
just thrown out
even if he is now it seems disowning him
the president-elect the people say they
want to have change you are an old
friend of the roger pax's how can you be
different probably my old friend rajafak
says when did i know the rajawatsa i've
been opposing them all this time
you come here today and tell me i am a
friend
you asked anyone
no you want any of them
can you be the change that sri lanka
says it wants
i will give the change that the people
want
the people see ranul wikram singer as a
close associate of the rajapaksa family
who they blame for the country's
crippling economic crisis
hundreds of thousands took to the
streets and ousted president gotta buy
rajapaksa and hoped mps would today vote
to replace him with someone different
as news broke protesters were stunned at
what happened instead it's a shock
result because nobody expected this
result we never expected
the politicians in the parliament
to give a decision like this
because the whole country was suffering
a lot
all these many years they do not care
about us on the spot where presidents
are normally sworn in protest leaders
demanded wikram singers removal we will
not stop this protest until ronnie
rickman singer a step down from the
presidency and we get a president where
the whole country can accept as one
president
[Applause]
they wanted change but now have more of
the same and tonight's rana wikram
singer said he isn't planning fresh
elections either can you promise sri
lankans an election in six months
they are not asking me for one
he won't be offering yeah
they have not asked me for one
would you give them one if they ask for
one if you are a citizen kindly ask me
that
but without elections it's likely sri
lanka's crisis will only deepen dominic
waghorn sky news colombo